this could be a weird four-episode thing
on a random channel that no one's ever
heard of it it's a great let's go make
it but for me I just want to make cool
interesting stuff like I don't care
where it lives
you know just work with YouTube or
passionate about it hello everyone
Perry here with a brand new edition of
Collider ladies night because we were
lucky enough to get the wonderful
ninotchka Khan in studio today the
director of always be my me welcome - oh
yes you doing that really I'm not just
saying this because you're sitting here
your movie just made me happy thank you
you need more content out there that
just like strictly makes you happy and
inspires you to do good things in life
you still have the Corollas what are you
looking at my back seat because we had
sex back there oh my god so what do you
think that it might be even smaller and
grosser than I remember yeah you better
still be talking about my back seat
thank you so much yeah I appreciate that
I wanted to go way back to the beginning
and first ask you at what point did you
know you wanted to be a filmmaker or a
writer oh yeah definitely writer first
you know I always like loved movies my
dad was a big old movie buff so he would
like wake my brother and I up in middle
of the night and you know have us come
out and watch like old movies with him
so we watched like breakfast at
tiffany's bent her Guys and Dolls like
all the genres and then he would
encourage us to talk about it he'd be
like why did you like this I kind of
talked critically about like what did
you think this character was doing like
why did you think she did that I know
you have a good dad I feel like my
parents just like sat me in front of a
TV and then when I liked it they just
bought all the toys and that was it
there were like Little Mermaid pretty
much now so but they made me sort of
think you know critically about story
and stuff like that so I think like that
was like the earliest things and then I
just like in high school I wrote a
column for my pate in the school paper
that was like a kind of op-ed just I can
do whatever I want like a humor things
do you remember what it was about oh my
god like I'm sure it was like about like
prom you know it's like getting your
driver's license like whatever you know
just kind of boring crazy stuff like
that I feel like
I mean that's very important to someone
at a certain point in their lives and I
guarantee ya like little things like
that could spawn a new story idea you
never know that's it well and I also
really remember liking because like
whenever the paper would come out the
people would come up to me later in the
halls or whatever and be like oh I
really I thought your thing was really
funny like I really liked it I remember
liking that sort of like time-release
aspect of being a writer you know it's
not like the immediacy of like stand-up
or theatre or something where you're
feeling the audience it's like they're
experiencing it wherever it's a good
thing you got into TV and film
production because there's probably a
big span of time in between whether it's
writing a piece of content or I guess
not so much in TV the turnaround might
be a little yeah at least a little bit a
little bit but still you know it's
months and stuff yeah yeah and film
school because I know you went to USC
mm-hmm
what made you decide to go there and we
talked about this all the time because a
lot of people always ask if I want to
break into the industry do I go to
school or do I not it's such a hard
question to answer because I know that
works really well for some people but
others don't need it and I think
experience in the industry is more
helpful in their cases a thousand
percent like I went to go see undergrad
so I was there for four years
I chose USC just randomly I had been
accepted into the general school I
didn't know what I wanted to do so I
just like put international relations
cuz it sounded like I wanted to try I'm
like I like traveling you know I mean to
relationships or whatever so I put that
down and then I went to like this
weekend seminar thing that my parents
made me good because I lived in Hawaii
and you know if you don't have a if your
family doesn't have money to like see
the campuses they send school sin like
representatives out and I was just this
guy was talking and I was flipping
through the book and I saw the school
cinema television and I was like oh this
is what I want to do and then the guy
was like it's very competitive to get in
and I think the deadline was like a week
and a half so that was the hardest I
ever worked in high school was getting
my packet ready for and then once you
got to USC was there anything you
specialized in or do they just kind of
broadly teach you about what it means to
make films well you have like different
and within the film school it's like
production critical studies and writing
and now I think it's a visual arts and
animation whatever but my emphasis
wasn't writing so it was primarily in
that but you know you you start to
direct they had like
acting for writers and directing for
writers I love that component of any
kind of film program if you had to pick
something that wasn't specifically for
the track that you were on that helped
you the most after the fact what would
it be
that wasn't specifically for the track I
was on I think it was like probably one
of those kind of like psychology classes
like the insight there's something
called a Content and consciousness which
I don't know what that means but
certainly the idea it's in a hat you
shake it up to this day I have no idea
but I like the way they were sort of
talking about like what's underneath the
emotion of story you know that kind of
thing I guess he has something like that
could help yeah it's pretty like
psychology I guess I was on the
producing track in my school and one of
the things that they made us do at the
very beginning was we to take a class
called directing the actor and they made
like everyone had a turn directing but
you always directed your classmates and
even though it was appreciated the craft
of acting before until you're being
directed and you're forcing yourself to
do something that definitely isn't
second nature to you right I never
really knew what that felt like did you
find that you were an immediate diva
like you didn't realize that not a diva
I like I felt like I was like like I
wanted to crawl on a pole and I I just
really didn't want to do say we're
giving you direction and you were like
what do you I feel very self-conscious
and I realized that like I can't make my
voice do different things with the same
sentence once I say it one way all I
could do is keep repeating it that way
I'm dialed in credible
now so we've gotten to school but at
what point because a lot of people say I
want to be in the industry but there's a
different thing when you actually feel
like oh now I'm here and I can do it
thank you even when you first start with
your first job sometimes it doesn't feel
like a real job
but that thing happens definitely not I
mean you know for me kind of going back
to what you were saying before it's like
some people just go should just go into
the industry it's good for some people
to go to school for this kind of thing I
think for years
for the final two years I mean I
appreciated the whole experience but I
started to sort of intern and get that
unpaid you know job like hands-on
experience and that's where you're like
you feel you're kind of in between
worlds you know cuz you're going to an
office you're not making money you're
basically like collating scripts or like
taking the Brad's I just
grips and like recycling so you're not
really you know your hands are all cut
up like it's not the ideal but you're
still on the Fox lap or you're you know
what I mean like you're it I interned at
National Lampoon was like one of my
first oh that was probably a fun one it
was I mean it was a huge fan and it was
cool to be there and you know I just
like liked being around like kind of the
legend of that huh I just remember
taking magazines and newspapers and
stacking them away in storage
just in case they ever wanted to option
something right at all besides that
which I didn't quite understand yeah um
what about people in your life that kind
of gave you a chance because I feel like
it's very important for everyone out
there to have I don't know that one
person to be the first person to throw
them a bone take them under their wing
was there anybody like that for you the
first person you know once I graduated
I'd written this script which was not
good but for some reason like she liked
it she liked my writing this professor I
had this adjunct professor who slipped
it to this woman Sharon Morel and she
was like Disney is hiring and I was like
temping and like do like doing sort of
odd things in the first you know it was
six months after graduation or whatever
she sent it somebody at Disney and they
were hiring in their TV animation
department sort of like in-house
development writers or whatever and that
was my first job so the fact that like
she would believe it I kept her and
that's it it was the perfect age for
that show oh my god adored that oh good
I'm so glad
[Music]
you ever think that you wanted to get
into animation before you were hooked up
with that opportunity um I mean I
enjoyed watching animation you know I
love The Simpsons but I wasn't it was
never something that I didn't write any
animated scripts or anything like that
and so I kind of just came like a
roundabout way to pepper Ann and Sue
Rose who was an illustrator who created
this trip was like you know I like
wanted to hire me to like be the you
know head writer and we developed it
together it was pretty amazing that was
grad school for me really was working on
that show cuz I learned like how to make
a TV series from beginning to end you
know you feel the pressure of getting an
opportunity like that so early on I mean
I just felt excited like I really like I
called up my they were like here's your
budget I called up my friends who were
still like my one friend was giving like
tram tours at Universal Studios my other
friend was like temping or whatever I
was like you guys want to come write on
this kids animated show they're like of
course yes we do so we were all just
super excited like someone was paying us
to write we wanted it to be like
Seinfeld but for kids you don't like
they wanted to just like do weird things
and make ourselves laugh and kind of you
know celebrate this idea that soon would
come up with yeah I feel like there
wasn't that many shows like it then - I
mean that was really that's really one
of the only things that come to mind
where it was like like a show about a
young girl who's like weird yeah I know
it was really took to that well that's
the thing you she had like this hyper
imagination so she would just imagine
herself in all these scenarios raised by
a single mom you know her younger sister
was always mistaken for a boy she had a
very deep voice Pam Adlon was the voice
and you know it was just kind of
revolutionary and it was ahead of its
time and we just had a great great time
working on it what is it like when you
finish a project like that especially
when it's still at the very beginning of
your career because I'll never forget
when I got my very first job and then I
fell in love with it and that show was
cancelled I feel like the first time
that happened it's so difficult to be
like oh it's okay I still have my whole
life ahead of me I find the next thing I
mean I was lucky in that sense because
we got to make 65 episodes so and each
episode was 211 minute stories so it was
like however many you know 130 stories
or whatever so I felt good about like
what we did that was kind
like ready for the next thing you know
to move on to the next thing so I was
lucky in that way and what was the next
thing how long did you have to wait for
that see I mean I worked on some
different like I developed a few things
over at Disney wrote a couple of movies
or rewrote some movies and then my next
like TV staff job was Malcolm them at
all
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so I was like you know let's try this
primetime fit let's try this ready for
humans thing you know so much TV
experience and curious what made you
kind of like flip the switch to
directing a feature film because I
imagine that production process is
drastically different yeah I mean for me
at least the way I've done you know
being a showrunner in TV like when I
created don't trust the [ __ ] in
apartment 23 and then refresh the poet I
said I'm still pissed about that I mean
I wish just how illegal is this but it's
illegal is that panda fat eye cream you
use you use panda on your face Luther is
76 years old shut up [ __ ] I hope we get
to do like a Christmas special or
something for Netflix would that be so
fun yeah that's the perfect place to do
I mean my mind immediately went back to
the Sabrina Christmas special which is
like like just a really awesome creative
opportunity for streaming platform like
Netflix that's what makes them stand out
so I hope they do more things like I
know me too
he said well you planted that bug in my
time we gotta get that going I wish but
yeah I you know so the way I approach
sort of creating TV shows is similar to
me to directing a feature because it's
all about kind of world building and
like creating characters tone and things
like that so there there is definitely
differences but there's a lot of
similarities a lot of crossover when you
first hit the set of this movie is there
anything that you didn't know from your
experience before that made you think oh
that's how they do it on a movie set or
any question that felt like a stupid
question that you had well I mean there
was definitely like lens packages was a
big learning curve for me like going to
the lens house with my DP who you know
Tim sir stret who's amazing he's got a
ton of experience he actually shot the
first Bill and Ted's Excellent Adventure
with Keanu 30 years ago so they do just
like a big coincidence I mean I think so
but this one we had counting on our
movie and he was like hey I know if your
memory on Tim he's like Tim and they
like caught up about 30 years of life
you know life or whatever but but that
was a big learning curve for me going
you know cuz I was explaining the look I
wanted I was going for this sort of
classic rom-com look of like the 80s and
90s but I wanted to combine it with sort
of this modern-day story was like very
2019 story
I'd like the idea of the combination of
those two but going into lens the lens
house I was just like okay what's our
camera package like I don't know like
Tim like I trusted you he's like what do
you know what do you like better this or
this
and so we would kind of just have to use
like very lean I would have to just be
very visceral because I didn't really
know the exact technology and now I have
after this movie I could talk about
camera packages for the rest of my life
I'm straight straight up opinion what's
the difference with picking a camera
package on a movie compared to a TV show
is all of that just like set in stone
from the very beginning so it's never
really switched up at all yeah like I
never had to do that on the TV show you
know cuz I guess when you're doing the
pilot you kind of do that with your DP
but television enjoy at least network
comedy has kind of a look you know like
it's I mean you can sort of paint with
you know within these numbers but you're
not gonna really break out of like the
traditional like ABC look or whatever
you know so that makes sense there's a
little less stuff to work on there what
about the editing process because one of
my favorite things about always be by
maybe is I mean just simple things like
having the split-screen and things like
that in certain music cues because it
really does add a significant amount of
energy and I don't necessarily know if
you had the opportunity to do that in TV
so is that something that you had to
kind of adapt into like the
pre-production so you knew exactly what
you were gonna do in that respect when
you shot everything well luckily editing
is something that I've had a ton of
experience doing in television I've
edited every single episode of the shows
I've created you know so I've over a
hundred episodes of TV editing
experience so you know I I really love
editing because to me it's like that
final rewrite you know where you can get
in there and you can craft the timing
and you can switch things up and you can
split screen stuff and you going into it
when I was prepping the shot list there
were some scenes that I was like I knew
I wanted to shoot them in a certain way
to allow for you know at this point in
my career I know I'm gonna want these
options and editing so it's like I would
shoot it one way then I would shoot it
another way just to have it in case I
wanted to do something different oh
that's fascinating that yeah I I'm
always like a big proponent of people
who can have an understanding or at
least a little experience in as many
different departments as possible
yeah helps the whole production I mean
for sure and it's like that I I would
highly recommend people get into and
understand editing you know there's so
many talented editors out there Lee
hexyl was the editor on this movie she
did like Crazy Stupid Love you know
she's amazing and she was great actually
at tracking the emotions of every single
character in every scene so I would be
focused on whatever you know Sasha and
you know Ali and Randall's character and
then she would be like oh but Jenny's
over here doing this you know I mean
it's just like she saw everything in a
360 way you could pick so you know a lot
about lenses you know a lot about
editing if you could pick one department
that you're not as familiar with to kind
of brush up on or get the 101 what would
it be it's still color correcting that
to me is you know that's rough that's
rough it's it's because especially
movies with this movies for Netflix so
there's three versions of color
correcting you have to do you have to do
HDR which is the high def you know the
modern tvs then you have to do SDR which
is standard then you have to do
theatrical because we had a theatrical
release and everything is different and
they explained to me like the projector
is gonna show it this way the eight
shares in it it's like it just at a
certain point I'm like guys what are we
doing like I can't wrap my head around
this Wow
so many things those guys are artists
I'm gonna thought about yeah the first
thing I ever got in trouble doing at a
job was I was a camera op for a local
news station and one time I pressed
record and then I white balanced off the
snow and I got a big lecture about that
when I got back to my office never gonna
do that again is there anything else
about making a movie specifically for
Netflix that's really different like
that or adds an extra piece of the
process I would say just that is the
biggest thing like the the different
versions of something you know there was
another we wanted to shoot almost like
the it like a letterbox you know style
like two four yeah ratio Tim and I and
that's what we were talking about and
then Netflix got on with us and they
were like hey you have to keep in mind a
lot of people are gonna watch this on
their tablets and on their phones and
our research has shown that people don't
like black bars because if you only have
a small space that they hit that one
option where
just makes it bigger but you're cutting
off some of the frame so we changed it
up so they have a Netflix has created
this 2o ratio which is not in any other
you know it's not the a Tripoli it's not
TV it's this in between things a little
nutty with that whenever I put something
on my iPad I never expand it because I
get crazy about watching the film as
intended as I'm tilting exactly so
they're like you don't want that you
don't you know that heads are cut off
and whatever so so we adjusted that for
Netflix we're constantly talking about
different I mean now with the rise of
Netflix and all the original content
where that we're getting from them we're
always talking to filmmakers about how
much creative opportunity they have
there some curious about your
collaboration with them you know what
kind of notes do you get from them or is
it just about you guys doing your thing
as intended I mean I have to say I've
had an amazing experience at Netflix
like they really from day one we were
all on the same page about what movie we
were making and they were invested so
yeah they gave notes you know at all the
regular intervals like after the table
read and you know as as we continue to
revise that getting ready for production
but once we started shooting they were
so supportive
you know they've come to set they would
like what do you guys need you've been
amazing partners you know I remember I
think was one of the last few days of
shooting Scott Stuber who's in charge of
the film division came and he was like
what what can we do and I was like I can
already say that we're gonna need more
money for music like without even
knowing I already know the music budget
too low he's like done and so it's like
what you know as a filmmaker like how
what else can you ask for it sounds like
a dream come true over there and it I've
heard it from so many people at this
point it's almost like yeah the pro
circuit you're good maybe you did a
great experience but like I've heard it
from so many different individuals now
it seems so sincere and like the only
way you could take certain risks that we
see them taking right now that's it and
it's like you know making movies that
have different points of views starring
different kinds of people first-time
filmmakers women filmmakers and just
trusting you to do the job they hired
you to do and that's you know that's the
whole thing you need people like that
around you the other thing with Netflix
specifically right now is they
like they're kind of making a really
smart move by cornering the market with
romantic comedies because it mean I'm
obsessed with box office and it doesn't
seem like there's all that much room for
romantic comedies at the box office
right now which is very upsetting which
makes me very happy that we have Netflix
so do you have like any kind of take in
terms of like like why isn't it working
there but it's between your movie
between set it up and to all the boys I
love before there's just so much special
stuff coming out of Netflix right now in
that genre they're killing it they're
killing it I you know it's almost like a
chicken in the egg scenario because I
feel like the lack of those kinds of
comedies coming out in the traditional
studio system in the theaters you know
created this void that Netflix then
filled with these movies and then
because you can get these movies at home
which is kind of a little bit the ideal
setting for a rom-com because it's cozy
in a way we've just never had that
option before you know but now that we
do I'm wondering if because Netflix is
you know making all this incredible
product that people are like you know
what I'll just watch it at home you know
what I mean I don't know which you know
it's an interesting thing I feel that
I'm thinking to the theater and I don't
want to ever see that totally closed or
at least not be isolated to just the
biggest of the big budget why isn't
right I mean I had I watched your movie
at home and it was delightful I got the
semi cozy couch with my cat and I was
just filled with joy and get your
popcorn you got your wine you know
you're like that's it do you see that
happening overall with the industry in
terms of like Netflix versus everything
else right now especially with you know
like Disney's got franchises like avatar
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe are we
seeing kind of that low to mid-range
budget opportunity on the big-screen
clothes you know I don't know I mean
like you said though there's there's
always gonna be something about that
shared theatrical experience like I'm so
happy that we got that limited release
because otherwise I never would have I
didn't expect it you know going in I
thought we'd just be on Netflix so like
to be in the theater and see people kind
of react as a group especially with
comedy you know you don't get that in TV
because again that's very solitary so it
was a it's it's a I can't even describe
it it's like an overwhelming experience
to see that so I hope that there will be
a balance you know and someone will sort
of figure out the rhythms or the
algorithms for making that stuff work in
the theater because I would hate for it
to go away it's like all the cards are
starting to fall I'm so curious to see
how I want to like fast forward and just
get a quick window into the future you
got to tell me who wins the Super Bowl -
because we put some money on that would
be nice if I could I also wanted to ask
you a little bit about Keanu
first all right you can do in the round
like does every single interviewer asked
you about Keanu at this point I mean
he's very popular he's a popular subject
if you didn't get him for that part was
there any backup or was it only him it
honestly was only him and you know but
it was almost like blinders on only him
because it was like we're probably not
gonna get him it's like pie in the sky
like first draft version but I'm not
gonna think about the backup because I'm
just pretending like we're gonna get him
you know what I mean like head in the
sand
ostrich style and then we actually heard
he wanted to sit down that you know we'd
sent the script to his agents and we
thought we'd never hear back again you
know those things just like go into the
ether and you're like did anybody hear
from Keanu like what's happening but we
heard back that he read it and was into
it so he wanted to meet and we sat down
with him and he was great
yeah so that kind of leads me to my next
questions I'm also fascinated by how a
marketing campaign comes together and
how trailer comes together was there
ever any thought to keep him out of the
trailer oh yeah
there was a lot of you know phone calls
and meetings and emails about you know
getting that dude we don't want to spoil
it but rightly so the marketing team was
like Keano is a big piece of this like
it is a draw and you can't argue with
that so the compromise was in the
trailer the full trailer we had him at
the end but we didn't say that he was
playing himself he just came in and
people like oh my god Keanu's in this so
it was like a compromise we know you
know he's in it but you don't know
exactly what it makes sense and
personally I didn't feel like it took
away from this fresh good okay all the
disclaimers do not spoil this we were
certainly we're not going to is there
anything from the experience of making
this movie that you're gonna take with
you on your next movie
oh so much I mean you know for me it's
just about working with people that you
absolutely love and trust and respect
it's it's so important in anything you
do but specially comedy because it's
it's so subjective you know what I mean
like it's not
no one's right or wrong it's just like
if you and I find the same thing funny
or not so the idea of working with
people that you have that shared
sensibility with that you trust respect
is crucial also one thing that I
actually came in with that I feel very
strongly about is a in comedy cross
shooting when when possible because I do
think it's exactly what you're saying
like camera on me camera on you you and
I are like vamping comedy gold I have it
you know what I mean I don't have to try
to reef as opposed to both both cameras
on me you know especially when you're
working with people like Ali and Randall
and Michelle buteau and just I mean
they're just Michelle buteau is like the
unsung hero of this movie
obviously Ali and Randle are delightful
but I want more people to talk about her
I know I'm me too because she's so great
and she's so funny and she's just like a
like she just will run and just give you
a ton of stuff you know so you just have
to be ready for it
is there any
future you think for deleted scenes and
extras over it Netflix like have you
guys talked about doing anything with
maybe some outtakes like that I we have
definitely and I'm hoping that there is
some sort of platform that they first of
all I think would be huge like if you
could go on Netflix to like your
favorite movie and go to like deleted
scenes or extras or something I would
certainly watch off for sure like on the
movies you like because there were some
scenes that got cut out of the movie
that I personally thought were hilarious
there's one scene where Randall's
character Marcus breaks up with Jenny
and it's so funny to me like Viviane
bang just it's hilarious and I'm you
know I hope people get to see that at
some point I definitely want to is there
any talk about maybe mounting an Oscar
campaign for the end credits song you
know what I've heard people talking
about that I would look listen three 6
mafia one so I mean maybe there's a
chance that Randle and Dan the Automator
could get in there what I would give to
see him perform that live on stage at
the Oscars I can't it would be all like
those legendary but I mean there's like
in Randall Park with hello peril
performing I thought you Gianna Reeves
that's the thing though you find these
hidden gems like that you know there's
something special when you keep talking
about them all throughout the air and I
feel like we're seeing stuff like that
more so than ever now totally totally
and it's amazing to see you know that's
another thing that Netflix was a great
partner with because that song is
playing at the end of the movie and
normally when the credits start you know
how netflix your box becomes like a
little and they're like next up and
you've got like 10 seconds to either
click out or whatever they were on board
with the song so they were like we're
gonna keep your movie fullscreen so
people can you know hear the song it is
so nice to hear that it's not grated
that I know change the model a little
bit yeah so is another movie in your
future or are you looking to veer back
to TV because I know you made the move
over Universal which is super exciting
yeah I'm excited
ya know I think the ideal scenario would
be to go back and forth because I love
TV I love to you know do some news stuff
in that space but I also really have
enjoyed this experience and would
definitely want to do another movies
I think hopefully we can you know it's
just a matter of planning I guess but
going back and forth and I'm so curious
about the experience moving over to
Universal especially when you had been
somewhere so successfully for so long I
imagine that process is like jarring and
scary but also really exciting
totally totally I've had a great time at
xx I've made some great stuff I'm so
proud of it we had a great run and I am
very excited to start like this new
chapter at Universal and like see what's
up but it is the thing that's like you
know when you go to a new school
basically and it's like it's going to
college right we're it's like you know
your high school campus like the back of
your hand and then you're sort of lost
and you're like looking around the map
and you're like where where's everything
I don't know what's going on I feel like
given all the success you've had you
probably had your choice of wherever you
wanted to go really is there any reason
that Universal was like that's that's my
place that's where I want my next
chapter well I really had an amazing
meeting with the whole creative team
over there like Perlina who's in charge
of the studio and her team that she's
assembled and they were like look we
want to support the show
whatever the show is like of course they
sell like their sister network is NBC
but they sell everywhere and I really
appreciated that like you know what what
is the content dictate you know like
this could be a weird
four episode thing on a random channel
that no one's ever heard of it's like
great let's go make it cuz for me I just
want to make cool interesting stuff like
I don't care where it lives
you know just work with people who are
passionate about it well interesting
things with heart that are all so
diverse I actually wrote down one quote
that I loved what you said and you were
telling this to variety you said there
are people who think change isn't
happening fast enough but it's actually
happening it's taking hold in a real way
and sometimes I think it's really
important that that gets the point
across but like getting at the specifics
and hearing those specifics verbalize
make them feel real so would you mind
elaborating on that a little well I mean
I think that you know I guess it is you
know it is real like I'm sitting here
with you you know talking about this
stuff
I had an opportunity Aly and Randall
co-wrote this script with Mike ghulam Co
you know they it was never a question of
who should be in this movie you know
what I mean it was always them they had
a story to tell they wanted to write a
movie that they wanted to see and it's
like the more things that succeed just
open more and more doors for other
people for other stories you know and I
think that like to me that's really
exciting
you know when fresh off the book came
out it was 2015 so it's only four years
you know it's not that much time but if
you think about everything that's
happened in these last four years and
like all those movies you referenced you
know I mean it's all just happened so
I'd rather be here in 2019 than where we
were in 2015 you know what I mean
absolutely so I'm in 20 you know 23 like
four years from now just think about
where we're being I know I like thinking
about that in a really hopeful way you
never you never you never know there's
so many things changing and there's so
many opportunities for things to change
and then fall into place for the better
and I always have my fingers crossed and
I have a lot of faith in a lot of people
out there now yeah me too me too and
it's like listen there's certainly a
long way to go I'm not you know trying
to say that there's complete parity
because there's by no means but again
it's you know we're in the right we're
going in the right direction and things
like Netflix making these kinds of
movies people like Universal wanting to
make deals with people tell stories
about people that you don't you haven't
necessarily seen centered in that way
before those are like the real things
that are happening you know another
thing that I feel like verbalizing again
always helps people out there especially
people who want to do what you're doing
right now is hearing about specific
failures and also because we just got
through like a whole bunch of TV pickups
and cancellations and everything is
there ever an instance where like
something you were working on didn't pan
out and like you were super bummed but
you know found some reason to rise to
the occasion I mean totally you know
it's so so much part of the game like I
was exact producing this pilot last
season that wretch enough for bomb wrote
and created and it was the reboot of
Greatest American Hero
starring Hannah Simone and I was so
proud of that pilot I think you know
retching I killed it Hannah was amazing
in it and it didn't go you know it
didn't get picked up and that's one of
those things that like you know you feel
that you know what I mean because I know
how amazing that she would have been
important that would have been there was
another pilot Courtney Kang wrote about
her story growing up mixed race in
Philadelphia in the 80s
she's part Korean part you know white
and
she loved Paula Abdul because Paula
Abdul was the only person that she saw
that kind of looked like her and in any
remote way and she want to be a Laker
girl and I love that pilot it was so
good and that didn't wind up going so
there's always gonna be setbacks you
know that you stuff you believe in that
for whatever reason it's not the time
for it doesn't make it and it's like all
you can I mean it hurts and you let it
you know you let them you know don't
trust a [ __ ] getting cancelled like
that was you know very difficult for me
as well and you know you get drunk for a
couple months and then you you sober up
and you keep going you know is there any
opportunity to back pocket some of those
things or like once they don't get
picked up is that kind of it
I mean occasionally you'll hear about
you know something sort of getting
resurrected in a second you know life
but those projects you know it's a
little bit tricky because it's like the
studio owns the rights and makes sense
you know and it's so important with all
of these shows and TVs and shows and
movies and everything to have such a
supportive group around you so I'm
curious is there anybody out there
that's kind of doing something really
special for the industry whether it's
over at Netflix or anywhere at all that
you say I'm looking at that person
they're doing something good for
everybody and I want to work with them
well I mean you just have to I mean in
all capacities for sure you know you
look at networks you know what they're
doing you look at stream like streaming
services like Netflix like the stuff
they're putting out and you're like I
want to be a part of that you know I I
love what they're doing I want to go
over there you look at different writers
and directors and performers you know
Kumail and big sick wasn't amazing he
talked about you know rom-coms in the
theater it's like that worked you know
it's a great example and and it was like
nobody could have seen that coming
that you know it's like one of those
things where it's like alright we'll see
what happens and the fact that audiences
responded to it was incredible and
Michael Showalter you know did an
amazing job with that Emily Gordon and
it's just you know creating
opportunities for people's stories to be
told in a different way I find so much
of that exciting and I have to just
shout out you know Ali Wong yes you know
coming up and just doing it her way you
know not fitting into any box or any
preconceived notion of like what that
should look
and you know staying true to her voice
and you know it's a it's inspiring it's
been so exciting especially like the
past couple of months I feel like I've
heard more stories like that than
anywhere you know you have someone who
yeah they might have had a big role in a
movie but they're taking their careers
and they're running with them and
they're creating their own like I love
the fact that Octavia Spencer in
particular is she's using her star power
now to make things that we weren't
seeing before and even give herself some
unique different opportunities that she
might have not had before that's it
that's it you know and it's like when
you have the chance you know what you do
with it I think is really telling and I
haven't seen her new movie I'm very
excited she's something else that I need
you know it's like she's having so much
fun too and that makes me even happier
for her even though terrifying things
are happening in that movie it's five
o'clock somewhere why does she get our
numbers
those earrings are beautiful Maggie I
know the trailer was wild
I'm Ilia I'm in I'm in for this what are
you into right now it like do you
actually have time to go see movies or
like queue up another show on upload I
know well I actually because I love it
so much it's kind of relaxing to me to
like just watch things that I've heard
great things about I mean killing Eve
just ended come on go get Jodie home
rent that you're doing I like her so
much like I really like some I did
something you know where they do those
interviews what they ask you like the
same three question like they ask a
bunch of sugar the generic the generic
like three questions and they just print
everybody's responses or whatever one of
the questions was what TV character do
you wish you could have written for a
past or present and I was like I'm sure
I'm gonna come up with something better
like in a half-hour what I'm walking
down the street but the immediate thing
that came to my mind was villanelle from
kill me I'm like are you kidding like a
bored millennial queer assassin like I
would write that for the rest of my life
I think she's probably one of my
favorite characters created and
reasoning it was so funny and she's so
good in that role it makes me want to
ask you more of our Collider random
questions you also want to share about
hunting of Hill House did you see that
don't get me started on that all because
I'm like not a huge [ __ ] like genre fan
so I wasn't gonna watch it my girlfriend
was like you have to watch this that's a
question alone I'll watch it together
with you my mind was blown har is my
genre so I like I don't have big
reactions to certain scary things
anymore episode 8 there's one scare in
that episode and it was hands-down the
thing that year that made me jump more
than anything
oh I know that's not the car the car
seemed amazing
I mean but for me it's like I get goose
bumps with the stuff like when Luke was
an adult and then you that man the ghost
the tall ghost that Olli has his back to
him with the bowler hat the design is
exactly and then as he's moving as Luke
the man is moving the things just
floating with him and it's so it gives
me goosebumps right now to talk about it
because it's like how you can't escape
your past yeah if your childhood it's
all about trauma and your childhood
trauma moves with you no matter what you
do and it's just so smart on so many
levels I was such a huge that kind of
thing would I feel like a lot of the
content that we constantly talk about
and that's really something special is
it'll take like a genre like in that
case horror or in your case romantic
comedy and yes we'll deliver on all the
things you know and love in that genre
but also add this extra layer that makes
you think twice makes you relate and
walking away from your movie in
particular the whole concept of you can
have a relationship and you can have a
career is really something special oh
thank you thank you yeah I mean that was
important too it's like you know we it
was really important storytelling for us
to like make sure that these two people
even though they might not come from the
same place they might have different you
know views on a lot of things that
neither of them has to dim their light
for the other you know and there is
compromise and all that but it's like
you don't want to suddenly be like oh
well let me give this up you know this
sort of traditional rom-com maybe female
characters in the past have had to sort
of diminish themselves a little bit and
it's like I don't want to see that you
know what I mean I don't want my
seven-year-old niece to see ya and I
think that you know without getting on
any soap boxes just to sort of say like
we're both equal here like you know and
Ali's characters at fault too it's like
she doesn't understand why he doesn't
want more you know and it's like someone
who's ambitious it's like he's so
talented and she's like don't you want
more you could be so great and he's like
now I'm good it's crazy to think that
you can have it all by like conceding
certain things that's what the other
person totally and like that's kind of
the that's the vibe but this gives you
in the end and it really it like filled
my heart it made me very happy thank you
thank you I want to see if I can think
of any good random question yeah hit me
with those colliders if if you could
direct one episode
of any TV show out there what would it
be and why God I mean one episode of it
we talked about killing II yes I think
that would be an amazing experience to
direct an episode of that if you went
the horror route and did Hill House Lee
would you ever want to do something like
episode six like I can't get the way
that that was shot out of my head that I
mean he's crazy
I read so many articles about that I
would be I would love the challenge
let's put it that way
I would love the challenge I think maybe
after take three when it didn't go well
I'd be like you know what we're about
having more coverage yeah exactly
I was like hey scrap this let's just
shoot a regular what's the background on
your phone the background on my phone
when I turn it on like my home screen or
whatever is this rainbow that my
girlfriend and I saw when we were on
vacation like that and then my other
screen is when you like behind all the
apps it's just this weird egg with a
cowboy hat floating through the sky I
smeared okay yeah where did you see that
in Taiwan we were shooting a fresh off
the boat episode over there there was
like this cartoon egg that was floating
around in love when you find stuff like
that you make it the background of your
phone because then it never changes yeah
it's always there do you have any movie
or TV props in my house I have in my
office I have a prop that was made for
the show we had Shaq with Shaquille
O'Neal as a guest star on a couple
episodes and he was kind of this failed
entrepreneur he's playing himself and he
ran like a series of car dealerships and
he had this failed line of tequila
called shakeela and it was a glass
basketball with like his head as a
stopper and the thing was like you put
it on the decimate we just roll off and
crash and that's why it never sold so I
have a shakeela bottle good I feel like
you have to have a box of tennis balls
somewhere to go I have tennis balls
definitely I have that hello barrel
let's see which other ones come to mind
right now what's the movie you quote the
most man the movie I quote the most I
mean one of my favorites the most but
one of my favorite movies that I
probably know almost all the dialogue
too is broadcast news I just think it's
a genius character study it's funny it's
real you know I don't know I mean now I
need to I've gotten in the habit of
asking people that question and then
going and just rewatching whatever they
say I'm putting that on my list the last
person we had instead almost famous
which I've seen like god knows how many
times I did just watch it the other day
because she said it so now I have to
yeah something like that
oh because we said would you rather
before and also I'm actually curious how
this applies to everything you've done
would you rather have too much time and
not enough money to make something or
not enough money in too much time your
colleague asked me that Doreen alright
so would you rather have a lot of money
and a short amount of time to do filming
or a short amount of money and a lot of
filming time or your project but I came
up with two he sniped your questions and
came into the London my life we're
getting video proof of this I believe I
said the one where you have too much
money and not enough time because you
could always buy a bunch of red balls
and just like stay up use your use your
money what day up what's your onset
advice my onset vice chex mix okay but
like a thing of it like you know I would
just eat Chex Mix all day and not do it
why I don't want this take this away
from me
I like that it's but I feel like it's
better than my coffee advice which
eventually lends me out of control but I
don't even get some of that advice I
consider that like medicine like yeah
straight up I've cut myself off at like
four cups per for a day no more than
that now let's see if he ask you this
one would you rather test screen your
movie or go with your gut test Green
definitely for comedy because there's so
many even if it's just for jokes and
seeing like how scenes play within the
you'll feel when stuff starts to drag
yeah as long as everyone's cool with not
like it's not like the body but you know
what I mean you're not like react
overreacting to me if it can be a
working tool then yeah definitely
okay I'm afraid to ask anymore would you
rather story and thanks a lot I think we
have to wrap this up anyway but I really
appreciate your time today thank you so
much for being here again huge
congratulations on this movie always be
my maybe seriously if you need a little
light in your life a smile on your face
queue it up watch it right now but
congratulations on all the continued
success and I can't wait to see what the
next chapter holds I appreciate that
thank you for having me this has been
delightful course thank you guys so much
for watching this episode of Collider
ladies night please like and share it
we're gonna see you soon with even more
of them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]